-I will say, you know,
obviously, you're based in L.A.
We were talking backstage,
your son is in L.A.
Did you -- Because I enjoy this
a great deal.
Did you enjoy being
on an airplane without him?
-It was amazing.
-Yeah.
-I've never enjoyed a flight --
a cross-country flight more.
-It's the best thing
in the world, yeah.
-You know, I got on the plane,
and I was like, I could --
I could watch movies,
I could drink wine.
-Yeah.
-I could just sit here.
I could sleep.
And so I was, like --
I didn't know
what to start with.
[ Laughter ]
So I sort of like --
I sort of did a little bit
of all of it.
-Yeah.
-And then it was all over
way too soon.
[ Laughter ]
-You and your husband,
I have heard,
have a different approach
with reading materials
for your young child.
-Yeah.
Well, I think our child should,
you know, have stories like
"Goodnight Moon," and, you know,
"Dragons Love Tacos."
Again...
-Dragons, yeah, exactly.
-We broke ground for dragons.
There was another dragon...
-Before you, nobody would be,
like, dragons or tacos.
-There were no dragons.
Dragons like tacos?
-Yeah, nobody even put
those two together, ever.
-Exactly.
So those are the type of books
that I think
our son should be --
You know, that we should
read to him.
And my husband thinks
that that's dumb,
that that's like "talking down"
to the kid.
-Oh, wow.
-And so he, like, reads him,
like, "A Brief History of Time."
-No.
-And like, Charles Darwin's
"Origin of Species."
Meanwhile, my husband has never
read any of those books.
[ Laughter ]
But, like, now that he's a dad,
he's like,
"Why do I have
to read him kids books?"
He doesn't talk like that.
[ Laughter ]
I talk like that when I'm --
-That's so funny,
because I feel like
what he's doing then is --
those were books
he always wanted to read,
and now he's using the kid
as an excuse.
-Oh.
-That's like me saying,
"I want him to watch
'Breaking Bad'"!
[ Laughter ]
-Yes, exactly!
-"Wait a second.
You want him to, or...?"
Yeah.
"I think it's important!"
-Exactly.
-And I want to talk to you
about your organization,
Harness,
which we've talked about before.
-Yeah.
-This is just --
Is it about getting people
engaged in politics?
-Yes, absolutely.
I mean, you know,
I think that artists have
an incredibly important role
to play in society and culture
and what we deem acceptable
in our culture.
And so with everything
going on in the world
and in our country,
we have been, at Harness,
my organization that
I co-founded with my husband,
"who talks like this."
[ Laughter ]
We have been creating spaces
for front-line activists
and organizers
to be in relationship
with storytellers
and artists and creators
so that the story of the issues
and the people
who are living the issues
and most impacted by the issues
are authentically represented
in the culture.
And so that's the work
we've been doing at Harness.
-That's great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You know, um...
Sometimes people will ask me
if I'm -- if I would ever
consider running for office,
because we talk about
politics on the show.
But it's a hard no.
But would you?
'Cause I feel like
you'd be very good at it.
-This is actually my
announcement that I'm running --
-Oh, good, thank you.
-...in 2020.
No, I'm not.
Just to be clear.
[ Laughter ]
You know, it's so funny,
'cause I think --
I used to have this
knee-jerk reaction to that
of, like, "No! No way.
I would never run for politics.
That's not for me."
But I think that's
part of the problem.
I think the fact
that we think of ourselves
as separate from politics
is the problem.
Like, whether you want to be
a part of politics,
politics is a part
of your daily life.
And so I think that we are
at a crossroads in our history
where we all
should be asking ourselves,
"Is there a role of leadership
and representation
that I could take on?"
And so it's not just
a flat no anymore.
It's we all belong in politics.
We all need to be represented,
and so I refuse to say no now.
And I think we all should be
asking ourselves the question.
-That's just wonderful to hear.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I would be thrilled, of course,
if you would make that choice.
Thank you so much
for being here.
It's just always
such a pleasure to see you.
America Ferrera, everybody!